[Music]
but on Thursday
even with the great external problems
that we have faced with the pandemic and the
war in Ukraine that has precipitated the
economic crisis in the world in our
country the data indicates that we are
improving
[Music]
yes
[Music] it
is the  trampling on the rule of law by
the dictator andrés lópez has
generated laws that do not exist, beware
these laws of embraces of complacency
with organized crime I cannot find it
in the constitution it is not part of the
rule of law the man is a
rapist and criminal he confessed
[  Music]
we are hungry for peace because peace
has been associated in our country and whose
side is
[Music]